George Kittel San Francisco 49 as in
physical 49ers tied any of the most
receiving yards by a tight end in a
single season in NFL history with 1377
last year the Pro Bowler here on the
Rich Eisen show how are you George
I'm absolutely fantastic how you doing
I'm doing great absolutely fantastic you
were three and oh man you want three
every fun I bet it is how different is
it right now for you then last year and
then the FIR and any of the years that
you've been with this team to be honest
with you oh well last year after the
third week Jimmy G was out for the rest
a year which was full toss you know a
little bit different attitude mindset
going into week four but uh no it's fun
you know we had a great group of guys
and you know we're all building towards
the same thing and it's just fun to see
you know the hard work and things that
we know we put them in this offseason
it's it's fun to paint off for us
so then why is it different let's start
with that instead of how why is it
different I think this team kinda has a
chip on its shoulder and it's all a coat
that kind of stood with me was you know
someone else coached you and Hannah you
know like you're you worried about
Pittsburgh another owing to you know the
injured fighter always the hardest and
no we've been you know that injured
fighter for the last two years you know
we've only wanted to engage in two years
so we we want to win and we're going to
play like we want to win we're going to
give our best shot every single week and
you know that's what I love about this
team is the first three weeks we are
deep is played absolutely credible the
last three weeks and in our office you
know we're figuring it out and you know
I feel like once we get that I think
it's gonna go really well what are you
singing ask George kettle uh you know
probably out not to turn the ball over
five times okay and you know and you
know make the Maples I think that's one
thing that we really missed out on last
year and you know last year we the game
versus Arizona Cardinals but I think we
had thirty first downs like almost 500
yards still lost the game because we
have five turnovers kind of a similar
game yesterday but we found a way to win
I think that's that's a big thing that's
a big change is you find a way to win
those games no matter how I do there and
obviously having Jimmy G here you're
heading into a bye week with him without
having lost a game as you pointed out
totally different than last year what
sort of chemistry have you built up with
this guy
oh you know it's increased a lot you
know it went from you know hello I'm
George you know the first time you
walked into now you know just have a
little information showing and being
able to hang out outside of football is
you know build a friendship I think that
a lot of the chemistry you know I in
that's building with everyone around the
team you know we've had a lot of the
guys here for the last three years and
so I think our foundation is very very
solid and on its with you know mr. Lynch
coach Shanahan and and I think that base
that we have is really you know it's
starting to show and I'm just sort of
looking forward to you know I kind of
wish we didn't have a bye week so we
could keep playing folk I bet I bet mr.
Lynch huh you call him mr. Lynch now I
was in Iowa for five years everyone's
mr. this okay just want to make sure so
does that because I'm I think I'm the
same age as John does that make me mr.
Eisen George yeah I know but mr. Lynch
doesn't run the 40 in a suit so I call
you
that's the difference that's the
difference right different are you are
you jealous that I want a 40 in my suit
then George is that what you're saying
oh I'd love to race again see with you
in the suit
that's for my favorite things are some
it's the only thing I watching the
combine come on now come on no I didn't
bar so high like an over/under on you
guys on your speed last year I didn't
know really did they they might have I
think if someone did I think you
gambling somewhere Chris you could yeah
yeah there are online gaming sites that
offer a line under time is it in your
contract you want to come to the combine
I'm more than happy to make this happen
George I would love it I would hey I'm
not that far from Hindi so we can make
that happen okay how far where do you
spend your do you spend your off season
in in the Midwest is that what you're
saying yeah I'm in Tennessee okay why
it's not about why Tennessee awesome I I
needed a place to Train and my good
friends you did back there I played with
about five years now minors listen
Nashville and so and Rick Taylor's wife
Siebert of close friend of mine oh they
both live in Nashville so just gave it a
shot and fell in love with it and just
bought out there actually no kidding
George Kettle here on the Rich Eisen
show how does somebody from Madison
Wisconsin wind up or at least born from
there wind up in Ireland how did that
happen
both my parents are from Iowa my dad
played there my mom played the
University of Drake that's where their
families are from so started Madison and
then moved around all of Iowa and then
ended up in Oklahoma actually from the
last two years of high school so how did
you wind up at Iowa just because your
folks are from there is that how that
happened
oh well my dad played there you put four
Hayden Fry back there and late 70s or
early 80s I did not know that I went to
Michigan as you know George and I
remember Hayden front Hayden Fry I know
it's just been it has not been great
no horn a second are you one of the many
big tenors out there who revel in
Michigan's misery is what you're saying
George no no no no I like watching the
big tent succeed I am I'm a big ten I I
say am I in the big tent okay but you
know I occasionally enjoy it what's
wrong
so when what uh what was your rooting
interest over the weekend from Wisconsin
versus Michigan then George omit I was a
die-hard Badgers fan until I went to
Iowa so I'm in my 18 years I was
Wisconsin Badgers man okay all right oh
yeah yeah I feel surrounded married
saying I was born on a football Saturday
when Wisconsin upset Ohio State 1993 I
was kind of born for it hold on a second
walk me through this and why do you know
this uh donors I noticed is a pretty
sure my mom's water broke on the way and
they got stuck in the game's traffic on
the way to the hospital
and so they had to get a police escort
through the traffic and in the room you
could watch the game from the hospital
room so my dad was like hey it's going
to be a boy no oh my gosh George on the
Rich Eisen show okay so now here I am
asking who do you root for Wisconsin or
Michigan I feel like an idiot when
Russell Russell Wilson weren't there I
used to have a Russell mania sticker on
my car in high school well that you
don't have that anymore right no I do
not no no well now you're three and oh
you think you can win this division
George come on now here we go hey you
know we definitely put ourselves into
the position to win it and I'll give you
the coach answer a all we gave ourselves
you know we we we guaranteed ourselves a
three and thirteen season so we're out
there and destroy I want to try to win
every single game okay now give me the
non coaching answer I want to win and I
know this team does we're gonna do it a
new week and uh to go and no matter
where we platinum out a circumstance the
manner the circumstances and want to
give everybody our best shot okay before
I let you go George what are you gonna
do on your bye week sir what does that
mean for all I'm going back I'm going
back to Iowa for Middle Tennessee baby
Kinnick Stadium is gonna be rockin okay
yeah that is just that that place
is just it's Otherworld one-of-a-kind
well it is it's it and not only that but
your coach is one-of-a-kind and nothing
give me a good faring story George you
got a good Kirk Ferentz story for me I
have a lot of good stories give me a
good one I'll tell you this on my
official visit there after they offered
me he's like you're gonna be number 46
I was like oh that's cool why my number
46 goes I don't know I have a really
good reason but I totally forgot thank
you and number 46 five years well and
now that's part of your Instagram and
Twitter handle you still haven't changed
that yeah I think someone else took you
kill 85 so it's whatever
I'm serious sound safe a tree root
that's of course and and and in my
favorite tradition in college football
is waving to the Children's Hospital
George they're incredible there is
nothing like that during the game is
just so special I'm just happy that I
got to be a part of that yeah it's a
pretty incredible experience
it is so you're gonna go to that game
and then you know I was at Michigan the
following week George you were that I
know I wish I know it's toughest I never
played in the big house cuz I registered
that year so I did travel so I never
played at the big house or at Michigan
State no man no I wish my bio because
next week I go to Michigan and no watch
Iowa work them but you know well done
George Keadle okay so two things you're
gonna hang with me in Indianapolis next
year you're gonna be part of my run
that's gonna happen oh yeah okay all
right that's number one and then number
two I'm gonna have you on later in the
season to check on all of these things
that you just you just told me okay okay
man thanks for the call George Congrats
on being Reno thank you so much you
gotta that's George Kittel 49ers tight
end right here on the Rich Eisen show
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app